[Musique]
encore vous c'est l'émission qui reçoit
des personnages de fiction que vous
connaissez forcément avec aujourd'hui un
invité qui a sûrement un gros budget
pressing je reçois l'homme qui crache
son verre d'eau quand il est surpris
[Musique]
bonjour
on l'adorent non mais c'est vrai vous
nous fait toujours rire à tout craché
tellement partout comme ça là un pub pas
vous êtes dans des milliers de sites
comme et pourtant vous arrivez toujours
être surpris quand on vous annonce
quelque chose d'inattendu comme par
exemple le fait que j'ai deux orteils oh
oui effectivement j'ai vu ce fun fact
sur vous c'est dingue à il ne fait pas à
huy non mais regardez le vote vert
demain voilà juste pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent bien votre
spécialité sur ces dingues vous
réagissiez quand je vous annonce par
exemple que si on coupe la tête à kafar
il peut vivre encore trois semaines à ça
alors là ils le savent est minuit passé
moi je suis féru de docu animalier
justement en parlant d' animaux je crois
que dans le métier on vous surnomme le
lama
presque aussi bien jouer là bas ils sont
deux gouttes d'eau
en tout cas je pense d'abord c'est tout
vous l avais envie d'aller aux toilettes
sales étages si besoin
des toilettes sont à l'étagé mais ça y
est on l'a eu mais j'ai compris il
suffit juste de vous annoncer des choses
que vous saviez pas le deuxième prénom
de ma grand mère c'est le frasil ghazi
vous rendez compte que vous avez enfin
qu'est-ce que vous allez le regretter
c'est contagieux
et compte la gueule ce père que les
bâches sont des vraies vaches et surtout
quand on sait de la moquette en laine de
yack domaine de gaillac mais c'était un
animal en voie de disparition on voit
qu'il parie sur ces réseaux c'est
terrible c'est tout cas force de
recracher moi j'arrive plus à boire et
je suis un risque de calcul rénal un
calcul rénal quoi les ou maintenant donc
c'est pas possible on dit plus rien on
dit que des choses qu'on connaît la lune
est ronde pour péter discrètement il
suffit des cartes nff bon petit
discrètement vous ne saviez pas venez de
lancer un processus que vous ne
contrôlez pas ramires or vous savez le
regretter parce que ça ne s'arrête
jamais jamais jamais jamais
[Musique]
contrôle pas
ce n'est plus rigolo à la fin je suis
trempé ne serait ce que pour le matériel
on va devoir s'arrêter là heureusement
juste après la pause je reçois un groupe
d'invités beaucoup plus sympa le public
de sitcom qui réconforte
merci
[Musique]
et du coup t'as jamais pensé à
simplement arrêter de boire quand on
annonce un truc je comprends pas la
question est-ce que je cracherais quoi
du coup